views feel like sometimes jerking off is
just a little bit better sometimes I
still do balls I do sex I jacked off
last night what a thing to brag about
did she watch you yeah she just sits
there looking at you oh she just feels
she feels the earthquake in the bed yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah why
doesn't she just Jack you often she does
sometimes because I'm like oh none of
these pornos are working she goes fine
dude one time she was looking at
Instagram and I'm like oh who's that
Fitness influencer she goes is she hot
and then I'm like oh she got a nice
booty she goes I know huh so she put it
on her butt picture put the phone down
and then she jacked me off while I was
looking at her phone and I was like oh
my God
I hope you just administered VR to you
if she jerks you off do you sometimes go
let me do it because this speed is
different yeah but I don't want to
offend her I'm all like
boy do you actually give her directions
yeah you should have like an Asian
backseat driver yeah I'm like oh to the
right oh okay